episode 2 Hari discovers that she has
super powers in the tried-and-true way
that one typically does discover that
they have super powers and that's a very
convenient mugger hmm
normally this is where I'd say my eyes
are up here
right on Nancy the trickster god
according to legend he fashioned a totem
which he gave a warrior named 10 - hey
youtubers it's Charlie so this is gonna
be my vixen episode 2 video all about
the origin of the tattooed totem or the
nause totem however you want to think
about it technically the comics call it
the taunt - totem if you're confused
Anansi is the African God Tonto
was the original aware of the totem in
the origin story and in the creation
mythos of the totem and I like the idea
that it's the trickster god or order the
spider God however you want to think
about him that creates the totem as if
he's creating it to create more mischief
like I'm gonna give you this great
object of power but not because I want
to help you because I'm a god I'm bored
and I'm looking for some laughs this
episode just explains a little bit more
about her history in the United States
they changed a few things from the
comics in the original origin story
she left her homeland of her own free a
court after her family had been killed
she is a pretty tragic past her mother
her biological mother was killed by
poachers she went to live with the
village Reverend then he was killed by
her uncle who was trying to get the
totem now the totem had been passed down
in her family her mother had given it to
her they kind of dealt with that in this
episode like it was an heirloom left to
her by her family but in this version of
events she doesn't know anything about
her biological family for all intents
and purposes she's completely
Americanized in the comics when she
debuted she was already an adult when
she entered the United States I thought
it was funny that mercury atoms shined a
light on the the very obvious trope of
convenient muggers as a way to find out
you have superhero powers the other
option for some superheroes depending on
where their powers come from is getting
dumped in a vat of toxic waste
DC Comics Marvel Stan Lee toxic waste
cosmic rays and convenient muggers the
reason I think she hasn't found out
about her powers before now is just
because she hasn't been in too many
situations that have triggered her
flight-or-fight response when she's
getting mugged it's like an automatic
biological response in order for her
powers to work she has to be wearing the
totem but it can totally be an automatic
thing
it's not like technology that you have
to you know press a button to activate
or shout a command or a spell that you
have to speak something so dr.
MacAllister the person she goes to see
at the university is supposed to be a
future love interest as Marc Guggenheim
tells it but as it seems right now that
shadowy figure that it seems like he's
working for that woman is probably
someone from vixens biological family
now remember in the comics it's her
uncle that's trying to get the totem
from her they may have just changed it
and it this might be like her aunt or
her cousin or something like that really
the next step from here is learning a
little bit more about those people that
are trying to get their hands on the
totem and her running into Barry and
Oliver that scene from the first episode
which was kind of like a flash-forward
but so far I'm diggin the series you
guys can let me know like what do you
think about the animation so far I think
the biggest complaint is that there's
just not enough of it which is actually
pretty awesome as far as criticism goes
I did see some articles calling out you
know the original Batman the Animated
Series and a lot of the original Warner
animation from the 90s in that they
green like 60 episodes for the first
season upfront but that was kind of like
a weird thing there was actually an
interview that I heard with the
producers a long time ago where they
said that Warner Brothers animation did
this weird thing where they wanted a
bunch of animation but they just think
green let's 60 episodes for the first
season they produced all of them and
then that was it
normally for like a live-action TV
series they'll greenlight like 22 to 24
episodes for a full season and then
they'll do season - they won't
greenlight 60 episodes up front so even
if they decide to not do live-action
Vixen which i think that they will they
could just greenlight an animated series
but they would probably air it on
television right now I haven't seen any
ads running on these vixen episodes so
this seems more like a test that it's
not something that are trying to make
money on because they wouldn't be able
to greenlight a whole season unless they
could sell ads on it and to make money
like they're not gonna make a TV series
for free you guys can let me know like
how would you feel about an animated
vixen series like as long as we get like
full half-hour episodes like 20 to 22
per year even if it were only like 13
episodes a year I feel like that would
be good but here's something interesting
to think about because we were all
talking about Green Lantern arrow stuff
the other day think about arrow and
magic in the lazarus pit during season 3
because they were developing this series
when they were still riding arrow season
3 and they hadn't introduced the lazarus
pit yet they really didn't roll that out
until they dumped thea in it a lot of
people include
were a little disappointed that they
didn't dump all of her in it halfway
through the season but maybe they were
holding off on widespread use of magic
until they got to vixen Guggenheim has
said the plan was always to introduce
magic in arrow season 4 so that's
probably why we didn't see Oliver get
dumped in the Lazarus Pit but by the
time we get to season 5 I'll be
interested to see what they try to start
doing if we if we already have magic the
next step would be pushing to outer
space because we're already doing time
travel everybody cross your fingers and
just say the Green Lantern oath ok so
what's gonna happen next is I have a
couple q and A's like Walking Dead game
of Thrones I'm gonna try to get out so
be sure to subscribe to get that stuff I
will be doing flash and arrow videos
just because so much stuff happened
we're probably gonna get trailers for
those in the next week or so we are
within four weeks of both premieres so
that is like the danger zone so trailers
could drop at any moment so just be
prepared while you guys wait for the
rest of my stuff to post you can click
here for a new trailer from Gotham and a
little bit about Tony Todd becoming the
voice of zoom for flash season 2 and you
can click here for my vixen episode 1
video if you haven't seen it yet thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight